NICOLAS GARNER: All right, so
hello everyone and welcome.
My name is Nicolas, and I'm the
Developer Advocate working
on Google Drive.
During the session, we're going
to see what is possible
with the Google Drive SDK, and
especially what some companies
have accomplished by integrating
with the SDK.
As you all probably know by now,
Google Drive launched a
couple months ago.
And what's interesting is it
launched with an [? AZK ?]
that doesn't only allow you to
you interact with files, like
read and write files on Drive,
but that also allows
third-party application to
deeply integrate with the
Google Drive user interface.
For instance, you can now, using
third-party application,
open files directly from the
Google Drive UI, and these
files that handle the file
formats that you click on will
appear in the Open With
contextual menu.
For example here on the
screen, a user could
right-click on this PNG file
and choose to open it with
Pixlr Editor, for instance, if
the user has installed it.
In the same way, we let users
create files directly from the
Google Drive user interface.
So inside of Create Menu,
alongside creating a new
Google Document, a new Google
Presentation, or a new Google
Spreadsheet, we also list the
application that the user has
installed that support
creating new files.
Again, for instance,
Pixlr Editor.
And we currently have a little
bit more than 40 applications
on the Chrome Web Store today
that handle a wide variety of
file formats.
And I'm actually going to show
you a few of these, explain
you a few of these.
The first one, which I already
mentioned quickly before, is
the Pixlr Editor.
So Pixlr Editor is actually a
really cool, feature-compete,
online image editor.
It lets you open many, many
file formats, and even
professional ones, because
it has features
like layers or filters.
Basically, lots of the features
that you can find in
a professional image editor
on your desktop today is
available on Pixlr Editor.
So using Pixlr and its drive
integration today, you can
very quickly edit and create
new images on your Drive.
So within a few clicks, you can
simply edit an image and
save it back to Drive.
Another interesting
app is Balsamiq.
Balsamiq is this mockup editor,
[? mocks ?] editor.
So whenever you're, for example,
designing a website,
a web application, or a desktop
application, you can
use Balsamiq to quickly mock
the user interface.
So if you're brainstorming or
designing, you should really
give Balsamiq Mockup a try.
And what's interesting is
Balsamiq chose to create a
Drive only version
of their app.
They have, for example, a
desktop version of their app.
They had already an online
version of their app, and they
made a standalone Drive only
version of their app, so that
allowed them to ship
that even faster.
They didn't have to handle
merging Google Drive users
with their users, and adding
the Drive feature.
People who use their Drive
version of their app are
always Google Drive users, and
that made things a little bit
easier for them during
the implementation.
And what's cool with their Drive
integration now is that
you can, for example, interact
on the same file using their
desktop app and their
online app.
So whenever you're, for example,
on the plane, you
could edit a mockup using
the desktop up.
And whenever you're traveling,
or at a friend's house, you
could open the same file that
got synchronized through their
Google Drive sync client
using the online
version of their app.
And have you heard
of Hello Fax?
Who has used Hello Fax
here in the room?
It's a pretty popular
app on Google Drive.
It allows you to actually
quickly fax documents online,
and the Drive integration makes
it actually even better
and even faster.
So actually, I'm going to fax
a document right now.
So let me switch to my Google
Drive here, and I've displayed
a bunch of the PDFs that
were on my Drive.
And this is a simple PDF
that just says hello
that I want to fax.
So all I have to do is
right-click on it and choose
Open With Hello Fax.
I installed Hello Fax before
on my Drive, and I get
redirected to Hello Fax.
So Hello Fax has actually
these two features.
It has an online signature
management feature and an
online faxing feature.
What I want to do is fax the
document, so one click here.
And as you can see here, Hello
Fax is fetching the PDF
version my file.
Here it got it.
And all I have to do is Copy,
Paste a phone number.
Here is our Mountain View office
fax, and I'm simply
going to fax that to the
Mountain View office in here.
The fax is being sent.
So Hello Fax has a lot
of cool features.
It's going to let you know if
the fax was successful with an
email, or if it failed
for any reason.
And I don't know if you've saw
that, but I didn't have to
sign into Hello Fax.
I didn't sign into Hello Fax
before the demo here.
Hello Fax automatically signed
me in using our OpenID Connect
end points.
So the same time it getting
access to the Drive file, it
also fetched my user
information, knew who I was,
and automatically signed me
in my Hello Fax account.
And actually even better, if
you don't have a Hello Fax
account and you open Hello Fax
from Drive the first time,
it's automatically going to
create an account for you,
again using our OpenID
connecting points.
So that makes a really, really
good first-time user
experience, and actually even
give you free fax credits.
So you can open any file from
Drive using Hello Fax and
start faxing it right away.
So here my fax was successful.
Another cool feature
is you can receive
faxes from Hello Fax.
I think that's a paying feature,
but you can get a
number, and when people send
you faxes, they're going to
write that fax as a PDF file
inside your Google Drive.
So that's one of the really
cool things with the Drive
version of Hello Fax.
Let me switch back to
the presentation.
We have here with us today
three people that worked
really hard on integrating
Google Drive with their
application.
And they're going to show you a
bit more of what you can do
by integrating with Hello Fax.
And actually they are going to
go a little bit more deeper,
show you a bit of code.
So it's going to be nice.
And they're going to use both
versions of the SDK, you
you'll see what was already
possible with version one of
the SDK, what is now possible
with the newly-launched-- we
launched that this morning--
version two of the SDK, and
they'll also showcase some
mobile usage of the version
two of our SDK.
And the first person I'd like
to invite on stage has been
part of our version one Trusted
Tester program.
And actually, I think it's fair
to say that they have the
deepest version one integration,
and the most
complete and deepest version
one integration.
So please welcome Till Vollmer,
the CEO and Founder
of my MindMeister.
Thank you.
TILL VOLLMER: Thank you.
My name is Till Vollmer, and
I'm the CEO and Founder of
MindMeister, which is an online
collaboration platform,
online mind mapping platform.
In case you don't know what mind
mapping, a little, short
introduction to that.
You see on the screen a mind
map, which is actually
graphical form of representation
of structured
information.
On this mind map, for example,
we see meeting minutes with
participants, with agenda, with
the goals of the meeting,
and you structure all your
thoughts around the meeting in
this mind map.
There are lots of use cases
for mind mapping.
For example innovation
management, project planning,
even website planning, like how
to structure my website
with all the sub pages,
et cetera.
And there are some personal
usages of mind maps.
For example vacation planning,
or even people who plan their
wedding with MindMeister.
On the technical side, we are
using Ruby on Rails with
Apache in front and with MySQL
in the background.
We also have mobile clients.
You see our Android
version here.
Of course we have iPhone, iPad,
and we will soon launch
an Android tablet version.
A few words to MindMeister
itself, or the company behind
it is called Meister Labs.
It was established in 2006.
We nearly needed one year to
bring up the first version of
MindMeister, and we had a soft
beta launch in February 2007.
And since then, we are now
nearly at 1.5 million
registered users.
We are profitable since two and
a half years, and we are
working with a premium model, of
course, which means we have
a free version, and we have
three paid editions to get
revenue and to continue
developing our product.
We were very honored to be one
of the first beta testers with
Google Apps Marketplace
a couple of years ago.
That was the first time we were
in contact with Google,
and also Google Chrome Web Store
integration, and we are
very pleased to be part
of the Google Drive
beta test as well.
And I have to say really that we
get a lot of users through
all the source, Google, so it
actually is a really great
integration so far.
And we are looking forward
for version two.
When the beta test was
conducted, we looked at the
API to actually try to
figure out what can
we do with the API?
Where are the best pinpoints to
create a great experience
for the users?
And so we came up with a list
of things that we could do.
Of course the obvious things
that we already have seen is
to Create new thing, like for
us it's Create new mind map.
Edit existing mind maps, in
there we also wanted to
support various different
formats.
There are a lot of mind mapping
formats out there.
For example, mind manager
[? former ?], or iXmind or
Free Mind, so we wanted
to be also the
editor for these formats.
Then Import mind maps
to Drive, of
course, from our platform.
Indexing, that was available
through the API.
Export mind maps to Drive.
Adding attachments from Drive.
And then, of course, MindMeister
supports real time
collaboration like, for example,
Google Docs or Google
Spreadsheets, and we wanted
to even take this
level to the platform.
And I hope to show you
that in a minute.
And then we added-- because we
already were in a run, let's
say, or in a sprint of
implementing features, so we
thought, OK let's do the whole
thing, syncing mind maps,
backup, et cetera.
What kind of APIs did we use
through the integration?
Because we created the use in
the background as well, we
needed to access the
information.
So we had OAuth 2.0,
OpenID Connect.
We also used user info profile
and user info email to get the
email address of the user and
to get access to his first
name, last name to create the
credentials on our side.
And then we used the Drive file
API to store and get the
files from Drive.
We also used the contact
API just to invite
people to our mind maps.
And last but not least, the
Picker API to actually get
content from Drive
into our product.
Let's switch to the
demonstration.
First of all, before you can use
MindMeister in Drive, you
need to install the application
through
the Chrome Web Store.
And once this is done, you can
actually go to Drive and
create a mind map from there.
So we just press the Create
button, go to More, and then
we should just say Mind Map.
And in case the user doesn't
exist at this point, it's
created the background.
The user on our side is created
in the background.
Everything is set up, and the
editor shows up, and we can
start creating the mind map.
Let's plan a vacation.
And let's do a trip to New
York, for example.
You can just outline
your whole--
we say [INAUDIBLE]
for example.
And continue mind map
your vacation.
I'm doing the whole
thing here.
And if we switch back to the
listing, we immediately see
our mind map in Drive, so it's
already synced in the
background to Drive.
And I can also open it
from there again.
But let's take another mind
map that I created
previously--
MindMeister Google integration
here, which is actually a
summary of what I told you
before in the slides.
And you see all the information
also visually here
with icons, with graphics,
et cetera.
And from here I can do various
things through Drive, or with
the help of Drive.
For example I can export this
into various formats.
And let's take for example a
PowerPoint file, which is
basically slides.
And I can just press a button
here, Export to Google Drive,
and the mind map is converted
into slides and then stored in
the Google drive.
Hold on, if I go back here we
see here it is, and if I open
it, it's basically a conversion
of the mind map
into slides that I can probably
edit, pep up a little
bit and have a nice
presentation
out of the mind map.
So back to the mind map, we can
also import files that are
in Google Drive, for
example images.
So let's upload a file
here from Drive.
I have prepared a little Android
tablet screenshot from
our upcoming release.
Just take that, and see it's
here as an attachment, and you
see a nice tablet version of
MindMeister on the tablet.
I can also invite people to do
the [INAUDIBLE] collaboration.
So I already set up this mind
map to have a collaborator.
I can do that through
Drive as well.
I just go to the Share button
in Drive and invite someone
else, which is my colleague
here in the first row.
And he just joined me,
Mr. [INAUDIBLE].
And we can mind map together on
the mind map, or let him do
the work by adding new
ideas to the product
section, for example.
So we have an iPad version and
an iPhone version, so we
support all of the real
time collaboration.
And all the content is stored
in Google Drive.
Last but not least, if we
go back to our product,
MindMeister, we have a couple of
features here as well that
are based on Drive.
If I go to the Settings,
for example--
first of all, you see all the
mind maps that are actually in
sync or that are stored in
Google Drive from here.
And you can enable sync mode.
So on our Tools tab we have
Google Drive sync.
And this syncs the mind maps
back and forth, which means
that they are stored in Google
Drive, but they also stored in
our product.
And we have a kind of table
that maps the IDs from
MindMeister to the IDs of
the Google Document.
We also have an export feature
here where you can export to
Google Drive.
So it packs all your MindMeister
files into one zip
file and stores it as a backup
in Google Drive.
Last but not least, the last
thing I want to show is you
can also share from
MindMeister.
We can actually share a mind map
here, and we get through
the Contacts API my friends
from Google.
So I can--
the Google Contacts, and I can
share the mind map, and
they'll get notification
and can join me in the
collaborative session.
I think there's one thing
that I forgot, which
is basically the--
oh the Picker API, I showed
that already.
That's it for the demo.
Thanks for listening.
Back to Nicolas.
NICOLAS GARNER: Thank
you Till.
I'd like to thank Till and his
team for doing such great work
on their integration.
I know they've worked
really hard.
And I really like this real
time collaboration
feature they have.
And now with their Drive
integration, it really feels
that you're using any
other native Google
Document format, right?
You can just share a
mind map on a Drive
with any other users.
If both of them open it from
Drive, they will be put in
collaboration.
That's really cool, and that's
the same kind of experience we
have in Google Documents, or
Google Spreadsheets, or Google
Presentation.
And now it feels the same, for
example, on MindMeister.
So thanks again.
Now, well I've already
unveiled who it was.
The second company who's here
with us today is Cloud9 IDE.
They've been part of our Drive
SDK version two Trusted Tester
program, so they have some
really cool stuff to show you.
So please welcome Rik
Arends, the CTO and
Founder of Cloud9 IDE.
RIK ARENDS: I think I have
a few slides here.
Oh, wrong computer?
This computer.
So what is Cloud9 IDE?
We're building a complete
IDE in the cloud.
That means collaborative
editing, running your code--
Python, Ruby, PHP,
and Node.js.
Cloud9 is built on HTML5
So those are our native
technologies.
We have code completion for
JavaScript, which is a fairly
unique feature, because
JavaScript is weekly typed, so
we have a lot of effort in
code analysis going on.
And all your code is
running in your
workspace in the cloud.
So you don't have any
differences anymore between
workspaces, which is really
great if you're trying to work
instead of trying to
synchronize environment variables.
You get your own little bit of
Compute and Run for your code
online exactly geared
towards development.
Teams can avoid configuration
issues, management issues.
We have a full terminal now.
We just released this today.
So you can do Vim and all
these kinds of editing.
And the workspace URL
is a sharable URL.
So one of the really cool
features I just saw was that
if you integrate from Drive,
you can enable your
collaboration features
in a similar way.
That's not an integration that
we've done yet, but it looks
very interesting.
So I said we use Node.js as our
back end technology, which
is awesome and a challenge,
because it means that we can
scale very well, but we
also have full dynamic
code base in the back.
So that means you have to think
about how you do things.
So the Google Drive integration
API, Cloud9 uses a
virtual file system
behind the IDE.
And this virtual file system
effectively abstracts all our
file access.
So that means that to make a
very nice mapping to Google
Drive, we effectively mapped our
virtual file system in the
back to the Google Drive API.
So here you can see that you
can then save a JavaScript
file from Cloud9 directly onto
your Google Drive, which is of
course very basic.
But it is nonetheless very
useful to be able to use a
full IDE on your Drive.
Right now we've virtualized
access, so that means that
where accessing the API
for every file.
We don't actually sync your
entire Drive contents to a
server of ours, but that could
definitely be a cool feature
if you also want to run
your Java source.
But it will take extra time if
you just want to edit it.
Another thing is images
and upload.
Here we're going to upload an
image and show it in Drive.
My video cut short.
But I want to show you some
code, some actual code that we
use for this integration.
This is effectively our
Drive integration
code that we're using.
This is Node.js.
We talk to OAuth with a token,
and then we effectively just
talk against the HTTP APIs here,
iteratively to get our
files and build up the
virtual file system.
One of the optimizations that
we run into is that maybe I
didn't look at the 2.0 APIs yet,
but maybe one of the APIs
can make it a lot easier to do
batch processing of lists of
files, because everything
is stored by ID.
You have to do a lot of
requests to get IDs.
There are definitely
ways to get more
tight integration going.
So if you do it really in a
basic way, it might take too
long to get all the information
from Drive that
you want to represent
in your UI.
So there's different
ways to do it.
I definitely could say that we
still have some optimization
here, but it's actually
a pretty clean and
simple API to talk to.
And another thing I wanted to
show was what was coming up
for Cloud9, because it's
a nice demo moment.
And you can all see that this
text editor starts to become a
little bit chuggy
when it scrolls.
For that reason, we have used
another cool feature that
Google is enabling for many
developers, and that is to use
WebGL as a text viewer.
So this is actually sub-pixel
anti-aliased text now.
So the browser is becoming an
actual really cool platform
with Drive in Chrome,
as you can see.
You can do this kind of
performance on a MacBook Air,
which is not necessarily the
most overpowered video card.
I think we can see where
we're going in terms of
responsiveness of
the application.
So soon with Google Drive and
an application like Cloud9,
the whole experience of the
application will actually
start improving desktop
applications.
You don't have to bother where
your files are anymore.
They're in the cloud.
You don't have to actually get
a lesser experience, because
we can now get a better
experience on the web.
And another really cool feature
that's a little bit of
a lab project-- this will make
it out into the release pretty
quickly, but this one is a
real bit more tricky--
and that is that because you
have now more screen space,
you can actually start
to do full code
traces of all your code.
It's two different screens.
But as you can see, I just
reloaded the server, and it
dumped a full code trace of
what is going on in the
Node.js code here.
This is a very simple Node
example that is just loading
files, and doing web sockets,
and that kind of stuff.
But you can see that as soon as
we get more and more lines
of information that are useful
to see what's going on, we
might also want to get a more
high-detailed view on the data.
So if you can scroll through
code tracings like this, then
it's going to be
pretty awesome.
The only problem is as soon
as I turn on tracing, I
effectively blowout of virtual
NIC somewhere.
So we're going to have to make
sure that we stream the data
to the client in a cloud
appropriate manner.
But other than that, these
are the two features
that I wanted to show.
I think I also have a video
of collaboration.
That's going on, let's see,
did I fall out of my
presentation somehow?
All right, well then
collaboration will have to
wait online.
You can try it out
right now online.
We will release the Google Drive
integration as soon as
we think it's performance
ready to go, but it's
going to come out.
You can try Cloud9
online right now.
We had a big launch today,
so I'm a little bit tired
actually after working
all night.
But it's pretty awesome.
We have real time collaboration
on code, your
own terminal, and the cloud
is going to be awesome.
Thanks Google.
NICOLAS GARNER: All right,
thank you Rik.
What I actually really like
about Cloud9 integrating with
Drive is that you can use Cloud9
to edit your code, your
Java files for example.
But you'll be able to use
other applications, for
example Pixlr Editor to create
the image assets of your
project if you're creating a
website or webapp, or even
[INAUDIBLE]
to schedule the development of
your website, and any other
applications you could think
of that are integrated with
Google Drive, and keep all these
files inside the same
drive folder.
So that's what's going to be
really cool is all this
interaction between
all these apps.
And Cloud9, thanks
for integrating.
I was really waiting for this
actually, personally.
I think it's an awesome think
what you just did.
The third company who is here
with us today is actually
pretty known to most Android
users in the room, since they
were developing the official
image gallery that was shipped
with most Android phones.
And they're now extending
their horizon and have
prepared some really cool stuff
to show you, using the
version two of our SDK.
So please welcome Austin
Shoemaker, the CTO and Founder
of Cooliris.
AUSTIN SHOEMAKER: Thanks.
So quick introduction
to Cooliris.
We're a Palo Alto based
company of 14.
Two things that we're mostly
known for, one is
the Cooliris 3D wall.
This is a browser plug-in that
has seen about 45 million
installs on desktop browsers.
And also, as Nicolas mentioned,
we develop Android
Gallery app that shipped with
Nexus phones back in the day,
and even through today.
What we're now focused on is
enabling a better, more
personally relevant, more
immersive experience to
discover media on mobile
and web platforms.
And so we think we can really
bring together your personal
cloud with the social networking
space, and create a
much more intertwined
experience.
And we'll show you some
of that today.
When we were deciding how to
integrate with Google Drive,
we had four goals
for this demo.
The first is to build a visual
timeline of all of your media
that's in Drive.
The second is to enable
you to search by name
or text in the images.
So one really cool thing Drive
does is indexes your images
for text using OCR, and also
recognizes landmarks in images
and indexes those
as text as well.
Super cool.
And the third is instant
upload from
camera directly to drive.
And finally, the app is enabled
to update in real time
as things change in the Drive.
And then after the demo,
I'll explain how we
built all these things.
So this is our tablet
app here.
So I can just jump into
Google Drive.
This shows me all of the media
that's in my Drive, so I can
browse through it in
this timeline.
I can select any photo to view
it in high resolution.
So I don't have to navigate in
and out of folders and go
forward and back
in my browser.
And, in addition to
just browsing
content, I can search.
So the first thing I'll
search for is flower.
So the cool thing is
that these are not
actually called flower.
It's recognizing that there are
flowers in these pictures.
This is all Google's demo.
So we get credit for this, but
this is fricken cool, right?
So if it can recognize objects,
another thing it can
recognize actually
is landmarks.
So if I search for Taj Mahal,
it will go through and find
all of the images that actually
contain the Taj Mahal.
And one really cool thing--
we just dumped a bunch
of photos from our
India trip on here.
In this photo it recognized the
Taj Mahal behind a bunch
of my teammates.
So this technology is just
amazing, and we're able to
leverage it automatically
by just doing a query.
And finally I'll do a
search for a place.
So I can look for Germany.
And we found this almost
by coincidence.
It's actually finding landmarks
in the images.
It knows they're in Germany,
and then it's
showing them in the app.
So these are all pictures
of places in Germany.
So it's really powerful
and automatic.
So that's an example of browsing
and searching media
on my drive using the v2 API.
The next thing I'd like to
show you is how this
integrates with sharing
in Google Drive.
So I'll switch over here.
Here I have two different
Google Drive
accounts logged in.
I have this folder of images
from Barcelona, and I'd like
to share that to the account
that's signed in over here.
So I can just go to the standard
Google Drive Sharing
API, and then Add the
demo accounts.
And now that that's been
shared, I believe
those photos are new.
I think so.
Yep, so you can see that the
photos from this folder have
been shared into my
primary feed.
So the next thing I'd like to
show is actually camera
integration.
We've built a very simple
camera app.
And I can take pictures, and
that's uploading now, and just
finished uploading.
So now it appears in the
Drive pretty instantly.
So I'll take another couple
pictures over here, and then
as those upload, those will
stream through the Drive, and
then we get changes from the
API, and they'll appear in the
tablet screen.
So those are the photos
that I just took.
And one really cool thing you
can do with this integration,
because we use Google APIs to
do single sign on with our
account, in our app you can
share photos to private
conversations.
So here I can select one of
these photos I just took, and
actually say I want to share
these photos into one of my
conversations.
So I have this conversation
going on with people back at
the office for Google I/O, so
I can just tap here and it
drops my photos into
the conversation.
And now I can go out and view
that conversation here, and
here are all the photos
that I just shared.
So all of these files came from
my camera, through Google
Drive, into our back end
service, and to the users that
were in that group.
So really easy to integrate
between the two services.
And that is what I
wanted to demo.
So now we'll get into how did
we build this, and a couple
things that we learned while
doing it that maybe will be
helpful for those of you who
are planning on doing some
integrations.
So things that we used, the
Objective-C client library is
in alpha now, so you
can get that.
That will handle OAuth
authentication, authorization,
and then provides a wrapper
around the API that makes it a
bit easier to use.
So we use OpenID Connect with
OAuth 2.0, so that gives us
the user's email address
and profile, very easy.
We request the drive scope.
So there are different scopes
that you can request to
authorize to different things
in Google Drive.
The drive scope gives
you access to
all the user's files.
This lets you build something
that accesses everything.
The drive.file scope gives you
access to files that are
created or opened by the app,
but since we wanted to let you
access everything, we
request this scope.
And we're using API's from the
v2 release of the API.
For browsing and searching
images, this is our recipe.
We request the files list, and
you can specify a query.
One cool thing about
Google Drive
Queries is their structure.
You can actually give it a
conjunction of search terms.
So here what we do is we request
from the full text
index something that contains
what user types, so like
"sunset." We request only
images, and we request things
that haven't been trashed.
And then when this response
comes back, you get a list of
file objects, and it includes
the next link that you can use
to paginate through.
So really easy to get a
paginateable list of results
for a specific query.
And a couple of things to note,
you can go and make your
requests way faster if you
do these things, and it's
documented on the API,
but I just wanted to
quickly point it out.
Partial responses--
there's a ton of metadata that
gets returned with every file,
so if you say which attributes
you care about, it can return
a partial response which is
much more compact, and it
loads a lot faster.
You can reduce the page size.
So if you say maxResults and set
it to something like 20,
the page sizes will be smaller,
and then you can page
more frequently and lower
your initial load time.
Enabling Gzip responses is easy,
and it makes responses
come back faster.
And they're more tips
on the API website,
which is really cool.
This is the next thing
that we did.
You saw the real
time updating.
There's not yet a push API, but
we're able to implement
efficient change pulling by
synchronizing from the change
list that's built
into the API.
This is basically the best way
to load a collection and then
bring it up to date.
So About basically tells you
about the status of the Drive.
So all of the information
that you need to know.
The most interesting one for
this is largestChangeid.
So every update to Drive
increments the
Changeid for the Drive.
And that gives you
a number you can
use to pull for changes.
So you first get the
largestChangeid, which is then
going to be a lower bound
for the changes in
any subsequent request.
So when you get files, then any
changes that occur after
that will be since the
largestChangeid that you got
in step one.
So after you start paging
through files, you can start
to actually pull changes at
whatever rate you want, or
when people hit refresh, and
you pass startChangeid with
the one greater than the
largest Changeid
that you got before.
And this way you can, instead of
re-querying and pulling the
entire list of results
back, you can
get just what's changed.
And so if you say includeDeleted
equals true,
it'll give you tombstones, which
you can use to remove
stuff that has been removed
from the Drive
from your local cache.
So if you use the ID of the
file, it's really easy to do
correspondence.
You can see, OK here's
a change file.
This is the local
cache I have.
I can either update it or
move it if the deleted
flag is set to true.
And then it returns a new
largestChangeid which you can
use in your next request.
So this is the recipe
for that.
It's pretty quick to implement
and very fast.
And there are rumors that they
push channel will come in the
future, and then we will be
able to avoid the evil of
polling, but in the meantime,
that's how you do it.
And then for uploading, there
are three ways you
can upload to Drive.
So for our camera app we looked
at these possibilities.
Media is the simplest one,
though it's limited to two
megabytes, and you
add megadata.
So we picked multipart.
It's a simple HTTP request
multipart MIME document.
The first part is metadata, so
you can specify the title and
any other information
you want.
And then the other part
is the binary data.
So we use that.
There's also a resumable upload
type, which is useful
if you have a large upload and
you want to be able to
continue from where you left
off if you get interrupted.
So that's great for
large uploads
on unreliable networks.
Using the API has been a really
great experience.
And I think that the search
powered by OCR and image
recognition is really, really
useful and awesome, and it's
great to get that for free.
And looking forward to--
push notifications will be
great; getting more metadata
around files, like image
metadata, Exif; and actually
getting information from
the recognizer
are on my wish list.
Though there's a lot
of work with now.
And it's very exciting to be
able to build experiences
around this product.
So that is all I have today.
Thank you for your time.
NICOLAS GARNER: All
right, Austin.
Thank you, Austin.
It's actually a really cool
showcase of the OCR image
recognition that is built in
Google Drive and not available
to you through the API.
So everyone, there is still a
lot of space left for you to
build [INAUDIBLE]
apps.
For example, as far as I know,
there is no application that
handles the following file
formats that are listed here.
Personally I'd really like to
see an animated GIF editor.
That'd be pretty cool.
But most generally, I think most
apps could make good use
of integrating with a user
managed storage, such as
Google Drive, And we really,
really need you guys to build
cool and useful Drive apps that
will make Google Drive a
really interesting
online storage
solution for our users.
That's going to be one of the
big, big selling points for
Google Drives is your
apps actually.
So please guys, build
great apps.
And that's it actually.
Thank you very much
for coming.
And of course I'd like to thank
again Till, Rik, and
Austin for all the work
they've done.
And we'll be happy to take
questions, all of us.
So guys, if you can
come on stage.
And if anyone has questions,
please feel free to walk close
to the microphones
in the room.
They're all fleeing.
All right, cool, we have
one question here.
AUDIENCE: The Objective-C
client API.
Is that something you
built yourself,
or is it open source?
NICOLAS GARNER: Sorry,
could you repeat?
I didn't get the beginning.
AUDIENCE: The [? iPad ?] app
with what the Objective-C
client API.
Is it a open source client--
AUSTIN SHOEMAKER: The
Objective-C client library?
It's open source.
AUDIENCE: OK.
NICOLAS GARNER: Yes, I think we
released it this week, or
like a few days ago.
It's built by Google,
and it's available--
I mean, it was already available
for our other APIs
we had, and we just released a
Google Drive version of it.
It allows you to easily do
things like authorization and
authentication using OS/2.
That's all built in for you, and
then all the useful Drive
API access.
We made that really
easy as well.
Thank you.
Yeah, OK in front.
AUDIENCE: Does Cloud9 support
regular Java?
I didn't see it on the list
of supported languages.
RIK ARENDS: We've just released
the fact that you
have your own workspace where
you can run Java, and C, and
anything you want.
We actually have a Java debug
integration that is very far
along, but we're just trying to
figure out how to actually
deliver this in cloud scale,
because it requires a lot more
server side processing than
what we're used to do.
So with the new VM support you
can run it, and when we get
the right data streams wired
up you can also debug it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I'll also be using Mindmeld.
I've been using [INAUDIBLE]
to do the exact
same thing for years.
So that looks really cool.
Thank you.
NICOLAS GARNER: Awesome.
RIK ARENDS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: All right, this is
kind of a more general
question for just Drive
in general.
So I know you guys have Picasa
and Google+ photos that you
guys store photos and videos,
but that's kind of separate
from Drive.
Is there any plans to
integrate that?
Because right now there's a cool
video editor application
that uses Drive, but you can't
access any of the videos or
photos in Google+.
NICOLAS GARNER: So your question
is about a possible
Picasa and YouTube merge
with Google Drive.
AUDIENCE: Or just even videos
from Picasa that you
[INAUDIBLE].
NICOLAS GARNER: So actually,
we have the program manager
from Drive right there.
You can probably reply to this
question in a more appropriate
way that I can.
GOOGLE DRIVE PROGRAM MANAGER:
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: All right.
NICOLAS GARNER: Can you share
the answer with us for the
video on the microphone.
GOOGLE DRIVE PROGRAM MANAGER:
So nothing too specific, but
these are definitely things
we're thinking about doing,
because we'd want to bring the
power of Drive apps to all
this different content.
But still very early
in that process.
NICOLAS GARNER: All right.
Thank you very much.
Next question.
AUDIENCE: I'm working on an
app that asks the user to
upload images to then be used
later to be displayed on the
web on behalf of that user.
And in the past, I've worked
with Picasa web to do that
work, or they'll publish their
images to Picasa web, and then
that will get pulled
into the app.
Should I continue to use Picasa
web for that, or should
I switch that over
to Google Drive?
NICOLAS GARNER: Could you repeat
again your question,
especially the beginning?
It's just that we get bad
feedback from here.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
So I have an app that allows the
user to upload images that
they would then later use to
share with other people.
Should I continue to use Picasa
web for that, or should
I switch that over to
use Google Drive?
NICOLAS GARNER: That's
a good question.
Picasa is really nice to share
your image publicly.
Google Drive is really powerful
to share your images
only to a selected set of
people, and you get nice
integration like what you've
seen with Pixlr
Editor, where you can--
people--
I mean if you share your image
was someone in Google Drive,
these people will be able to
edit it or open it with Pixlr
for example.
That's something you don't get
the right now on Picasa.
The pica size is a little bit
better for sharing the image
just publicly.
People can see your albums,
and stuff like this.
So for now, it's up to you
to make that choice, and
hopefully we can work on some
better Picasa and Google Drive
integration in the future and
provide an even better
experience, the better
of both.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: My question
is about the--
how granular is the scope
limitation on applications
that use Google Drive?
In the example that was shown,
you have a scope for your
entire Google Drive.
Can you limit by, let's say,
file type, like only images,
for example?
NICOLAS GARNER: So
not right now.
Right now the only scopes that
are available are the full
access scope.
So for example the one you guys
are using at Cooliris and
you guys are using at Cloud9.
And for example, MindMeister
here is using the other type
of scope, which is the
profile scope.
And in here, you have to
actually use the Google Drive
UI to open files.
And only the file that has been
opened through to Drive
UI, or through the picker--
there's also a little
JavaScript widget which
you can integrate
into your web app--
and only the files that the user
has manually selected to
open through our UI will be wait
listed for you to access
through the API.
So this is the profile scope,
only accesses the files that
the user has chosen to open.
But we're working on more
scopes as well.
That's actually a really good
idea, for example, allowing an
app only to access images, or
allowing an app to only access
files that are in a specific
folder, for example.
That's a pretty good feature
request and definitely some
things that we are considering
which might get
added in the future.
So thank you.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So, just interested
in the Google Drive offline
experience.
And so if I'm collaborating with
somebody else, and I go
jump on a plane, and then
they're changing the document,
I'm just wondering with each
application what I could
experience.
In other words, is it like
[? GitHub ?] like replication?
Is it like a paragraph
level replication?
Is it document level
replication
when I sync back up?
NICOLAS GARNER: So you're
talking when you're using
specifically the sync clients,
right, and all the files get
synced to your hard disk?
So actually if you modify them
with anything and you come
back online, this file will
automatically detect the
changes, and when you get your
connection back we'll start
syncing them back
to Google Drive.
It's currently how it works.
So as soon as you get back
online, the sync client will
start sending the changed files
back to Google Drive.
Does that answer your
question, sir?
AUDIENCE: Not quite, because
I'm interested in Federated
databases, at what level
I'm able to merge.
Is it at the document level, so
in other words, if we both
make a change--
NICOLAS GARNER: You mean, if
two persons change the same
file, and in a different
way, and want to
merge that doc, right?
So currently, actually I don't
really know how that works.
I think it's probably the latest
that's going to win.
So the one with the latest date
that we're going to keep.
We don't currently merge, as far
as I know, the content of
the files themselves.
Though we're working on some
stuff in that area that are
going to be available in the
API, but I can't tell you more
at that point.
So that will be useful
in that area.
AUDIENCE: Thanks very much.
It's a good answer.
NICOLAS GARNER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: A related question,
on the Cloud9 app that you
were showing earlier, it looked
like you had multiple
people coordinating on
the same workspace.
Is there any synchronization
going on through your Drive
API, or is that all
out of band?
RIK ARENDS: Well we were just
accessing, effectively, the
API like a virtual
file system.
So another way to do it is to
sync to your local drive,
which is actually a really
good idea if
you want to run code.
The way to think of the
collaborative workspace is
that it's really a single
workspace, so
you're working together.
It's not a synchronization thing
like get or anything.
You're working together
on the same files.
Or you're working on your own
workspace, and then you use
get to sync source.
Right?
It's two different ways
of collaboration.
AUDIENCE: Right, but in the
virtual file system case in
prior systems that do things
like that, if you have
multiple users on the virtual
file system at the same time,
and this is a connectionless
kind of environment on the
web, what happens if the
connection drops for a little
bit, so both of--
RIK ARENDS: We have a
collaboration algorithm that
deals with that.
So it's like OT but different.
It's a different algorithm
that's behind
the actual text syncing.
It's actually really
interesting.
We can talk about that.
But that's more of a--
you're collaboratively working
on the document, and if
something dies, and you go
offline, and you close your
browser, then your edit stuff
in that browser will be gone
unless you have been online.
It's ethereal, so you do need
to make sure that you save
your file, or that one
person takes the
authority on the file.
It will autosave, but it
doesn't really take the
responsibility away that you're
actually writing code.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Yeah I think I'll have
to take it offline.
RIK ARENDS: So it works for the
real case, but you could
always find an edge case, like,
yeah I went offline, and
then I flew there, and then I
wrote some code, and then I
flipped my computer, and now I
have two de-synced things.
You could also just copy
some code over.
You don't have to implement get
to have use cases that are
really far out solved.
AUDIENCE: Right, well that's
why recent file systems
usually don't do multiple users
mapping the same file
for right at the same time.
RIK ARENDS: Yes, I think we
need to separate those use
cases pretty clearly, so you can
have two different ways of
dealing with synchronization.
NICOLAS GARNER: Thank you.
RIK ARENDS: Can only use offline
files on a Chromebook,
or can I view pictures through
a Cooliris plug-in on a
Chromebook if they're offline?
AUSTIN SHOEMAKER: So how would
the user access Google Drive
if they're offline
in Cooliris?
AUDIENCE: On the Chromebook.
AUSTIN SHOEMAKER: Well right
now, this is an online demo.
So every time you do something
it makes an API request.
So if we wanted to, we could
synchronize the image metadata
and thumbnails to the local
device and let you browse
through it, and then use the
changes API to sync and bring
it up to date.
So we could do an incremental
update when you come online.
So we haven't built that, but
it would be easy to build
using the API.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And the second question was,
for the scope in the Drive
list, it's limited to the files
you've registered, is
that correct?
Or you can see other files
that you have registered?
NICOLAS GARNER: Sorry, can you
again say the beginning of
your question?
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Yes, for the Google
Drive list API, if I've
registered my plug in with one
particular file type, is the
scope limited to only seeing
that particular file type, or
can I see other file types?
So for example, let's say
I have registered jpeg.
Can I see PDFs as well?
NICOLAS GARNER: If you're
listing files using the API--
so there is actually--
I think you guys
are doing that.
You're filtering
on the images.
You're probably using the
search query parameter?
AUSTIN SHOEMAKER: We use files
list, and in the query
parameters you can say MIME type
equals and then specify
the MIME type that you
want to filter by.
In terms of access control,
the drive scope gives you
access to all files.
The drive dot file scope gives
you access only to files
opened or created by
the Google Drive
API, as Nicolas said.
So you can filter using the API,
but there's no way to get
permission to a single file type
via [INAUDIBLE] scope.
NICOLAS GARNER: Yes.
Not just scope, but when you
search, specifically you can
search and list files of only
certain MIME types, which you
can list, and you can list
multiple MIME types, right?
AUSTIN SHOEMAKER: Yeah.
Another question?
AUDIENCE: Last question maybe.
Cloud9 is great.
I use it for Node.js
development, thank you.
Is there any chance that you
will actually build in the
synchronization to
Google Drive?
It would be a really nice and
quick way to get a local
instance of my Node.js app
running as a snapshot or
working directly, instead
of using get.
RIK ARENDS: Yeah totally.
I really like the idea of
synchronizing the Google Drive
or part of a sub-directory
of Google Drive--
preferably not the
whole thing--
to one of our cloud
workspaces.
I think that's a really
cool way to do it.
We do have to put some fences
up, as I said, about the use
cases because, DVCS doesn't
exist for no reason.
And so you need to make sure
that if you collaborate, you
collaborate with different
people in different time
zones, you can use DVCS because
you're not pair
programming.
And when you're actively on
Skype or on a new fancy HTML 5
audio link, which we'll
hopefully have soon, you can
use clicks, Cloud9 to pair
program and to do that.
So the gradient between this
asynchronous collaboration and
a synchronous collaboration will
fill in over time with
different types of code
review, asynchronous,
integration with issues, there's
a whole gradient in
between, but that
will take time.
All right, thank you.
AUDIENCE: All right.
NICOLAS GARNER: All right, if
this is it, thank you very
much again everyone for staying
and for attending.
And Thank you guys
in implementing
Drive on your product.